you're going through my grading your
monolithic application to micro-services
on gk but you've had a roadblock there
are so many features and services in
your application and you don't know
which ones you should migrate first stay
tuned to find out more in today's
episode of get cooking and cloud
[Music]
when you plan your migration it's
tempting to start with features that are
trivial to migrate this might be a quick
win but might not benefit your project
the most over the long term instead of
diving straight into the migration you
should spend time evaluating each
feature and create a plan for its
migration and to do so there's a list of
ingredients that can help start for the
business process evaluation don't forget
that this will be a learning experience
and there will be mistakes to learn from
so for that reason the initial efforts
should not involve business critical
systems but they should still represent
a significant use case for the team to
learn from from a design and development
point of view you want to pick features
that have the least number of
dependencies in which are easy to
refactor if necessary and also consider
the cost and complexity of developing a
refactoring as needed from operations
point of view think about features that
can afford the downtime of the card or
window if you need to minimize downtime
migrating features that require high
availability can mean extra work and
finally choose teams that have well
defined processes to lead the initial
efforts because you want them to lead
the way for this migration journey and
understand that they will encounter new
challenges for which they must find
solutions taking all these factors into
account this recipe calls for divide and
conquer approach where we find
challenging but meaningful features the
ideal feature requires little
refactoring is stateless has no external
data requirements and has few or no
dependencies let's consider our friends
at the ice cream theory and their
migration since they're thinking about a
full migration of their website to micro
services a good migration order for them
could be that they migrate the front end
first then think about the stateless
features next could be the features with
independent data sets such as services
that list their brick-and-mortar stores
and then finally come to features with
shared data sets like the business logic
of the platform itself the platform
front end followed by any stateless
features like a currency conversion
system go first because they usually
have few dependents and often require
limited refactoring because in the
initial migration recipe the backend API
is still being served
from the legacy data center a runtime
hosted on-premises are on another cloud
after stateless features components
whose data sets have no dependencies on
other data sets such as services to list
the brick-and-mortar store of the next
to migrate these are easier to extract
and move to the modern storage system
like cloud storage or cloud fire store
for managed data storage cloud sequel
for relational data or cloud fire store
or datastore for the document base no
sequel data finally features with shared
data sets like the business logic of the
e-commerce platform are the hardest to
migrate because of the requirements for
consistency distribution access and
latency across the legacy and new
services since data migration is not as
simple we are dedicating the entire next
episode to it
stay tuned well there you have it if you
are looking to migrate a monolithic
application to micro services then
you've got a recipe to decide which
features to migrate first stay tuned for
the next episode where we will learn
about the data migration strategies
that's all for today on get cooking in
cloud if you would like to see more
content like this
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel
you
[Applause]
[Music]